welcome everybody to endgame school
light black to move and it looks like
black is doomed because they're
eventually going to lose this c5 pawn
white's king position is just too active
even if they start with a move like a5
gaining the opposition white's king is
too close to the pawn they will
eventually be able to regain the
opposition and once that happens black
will lose the c5 pawn and the game so
what is black to do here in this
position black played the brilliant move
king b6 which looks like it only loses
the game even quicker after king d6 but
black has a very sneaky plan which is to
play a6 in this position and now after
king d5 king a5 and what is white to do
black will shuffle their king between a5
and b6 forever whenever the king is on
a5 the c5 pawn cannot be captured
because of stalemate and whenever the
king is on b6 neither the c pawn nor the
a pawn can be captured well because
they're defended by the king so black
pulls out a very tricky stalemate
resource here and that's what we're
going to be looking today and i know it
might seem simple stalemate but there
can be a lot of really cool stalemate
defensive resources in end games and so
by looking at some positions where these
stalemate resources are possible you are
more likely to be aware of these
resources and be on high alert to find
them in your games they're also very
very satisfying let's take a look at
some more examples this game was between
nikolevsky and taimanov in 1966. white
started with d4 the pawn breakthrough
and black can't take this if c takes d4
then c5 white makes a pass pawn and the
king will be outside of the box if the
knight ever tries to approach the bishop
can simply capture this black is going
to lose this one so taimanov started
with knight g6 instead
d takes c5d takes c5 bishop takes g6
king takes g6 and now we have this king
and pawn end game where white has the
connected pass pawn and black has an
outside past pawn it's very important
that black's king stays inside of the
box of this connected pass pawn they can
never leave it and the position may look
promising for white at first but
eventually you realize that black can
always keep their king inside of the box
and keep their h pawn defended as well
so white will not be able to make
progress even if the white king gets to
h4 black can always be defending on
either g6 or g5 as long as black doesn't
blunder white will not be able to make
any progress here so white goes for the
different plane they go for d6
sacrificing their d-pawn for black's
h-pawn king f6 king takes h5 king e6
king g5 king takes d6 and now we have
this very familiar position after king
e5 king b6 where white plays king d5 and
black has this stalemate resource with
king a5 king takes c5 the game ended in
a draw this next game was played between
chigorian and tarash in 1905. in the
game should we play g takes f6 but this
blunders away the game because after g
takes f6 there is no more stalemate
resource black's king is too active the
game concluded king g4 king e4 king h3
king f4 and white resigned here because
they're going to lose both of their
pawns however going back to this
position white actually had a brilliant
stalemate resource with not the move g6
if white plays g6 black plays h5 there
is no stalemate resource white will lose
the c pawn and the game but instead you
start with king g4 and after king e4 g6
now h5 is no longer possible h5 makes no
progress for black in fact you're just
giving up a pawn the stalemate resource
still exists so black goes for h6
instead but we still have this king h5
stalemate resource the king will shuffle
between h5 and g4 forever and the game
is a draw it is important to calculate
what happens if black takes this pawn
which if h takes g6 f takes g6 f5 check
king g5 f4 h5 f3 h6 g takes h6 king
takes h6 f2 g7 both sides queen and king
and queen versus king and queen is
almost always a draw unless one of the
kings is very close to being checkmated
which is not the case here so this would
be a draw as well too bad chigorian did
not see this and played g takes f6
instead but over one century later it
has proof for a very nice learning
opportunity for the rest of us so thank
you sigourian this next position may
look a little familiar that's because
it's the position we just looked at
except everything is shifted one rank
down in the previous example we started
setting up the stalemate with the king
move however here king g3 actually loses
and it's because of this line after king
e3 now if you play g5 you have to
remember that black doesn't have to push
black can actually take this and this
line may look a little familiar where in
the previous position we actually
promoted at the same time but in this
position white is much much too slow
black will promote and black will win
this game so what is white just losing
in this position then you have to
remember why we couldn't start with the
pawn in the previous position previously
if we started with g5 black could
advance their pawn two squares to
prevent white's king from getting close
to set up the stalemate however that is
not possible in this position black's
best tri is h5 but we simply play king
g3 king e3 and king h4 we have our same
stalemate and white gets the draw here
very nice black to move in this next
position and it looks like white is
totally losing black is gonna pick up
these kingside pawns have two connected
pass pawns which will eventually win him
the game so this should be a pretty easy
win for black right king g4 a5 king
takes h5 i don't really know what
white's doing but we'll just continue
with our plan king d2 king takes g6 king
c2 have you realized it yet king f5 king
b2 and oh no
oh my goodness i just realized king e4
king a3 king d3 king a4
i just realized that after king takes c3
and a3 there's nothing black can do to
stop the stalemate here king b2 and the
game was
drawn so black cannot be too hasty here
white wants to play a5 bring their king
to a4 play a3 and that will be a self
stalemate you might be thinking well
let's just start with a5 if we play a5
then white can't play a5 so i mean we
still have this plan we'll pick up these
king side pawns make two connected pass
pawns we'll be good to go this is
actually worse for black in fact a5 is
not a drawing move but it is a losing
move after king e3 king g4
black's plane does not work out because
white protects their g6 pawn not only
that but your g pawn is doomed white
will capture this and promote first
promoting with check black is completely
lost here so king g4 doesn't work a5
doesn't work we have to be a little more
direct with our king movements the only
winning move in this position is king f4
now if white tries for a5 we play king
e4 gaining opposition king d2 king f3
and we are now in time to capture the c
pawn and move our king out of the way
before white is able to stalemate
themselves it's very important here not
to play king b2 because once again now
after a3 two pieces guard the b3 square
this is gonna be a stalemate again
it's a very interesting defensive
resource for white here but if you
thought that was wild let's look at the
next position this is a super wild end
game study black has the outside past
pawn but white is looking to make an
outside pass pawn of their own so of
course as white we're going to start
with b4 with this move we're now
threatening to play a5 as white so black
must bring their king closer so that
they're inside the box if white were to
play this move black plays king d4 and
here the winning technique for white
seems pretty clear right we'll play c3
the c pawn can never be captured because
a5 will make a pass pawn and the pawn
will promote the c pawn protects the b
pawn and the a pawn can never be
attacked because if the king ever comes
to the third rank we're gonna play a5
make a pass pawn and promote so all of
white's pawns seem to be protected here
we can simply capture this pawn bring
the king over capture some more pawns
promote and checkmate black you might
calculate something like this king d5
king g5 king c4 king h6 king d5 king
takes h7 king c4 king g6 king d5 white
gets their king over here captures the
rest of these pawns and wins the game
whenever you have king and pawn end
games it's always important to be aware
of all of your opponent's pawn breaks
though here black has two b5 doesn't
work because we simply play a5 create
the connected pass pawn and this will be
winning for white the other palm break
though is a little bit more unclear what
if black plays c5 well here we don't
want to take obviously it leaves our
pawns much too weak but we can play b5
once again the king can never come to
the third rank because we'll play a5
make it past pawn and promote so this a
pawn can still never be attacked the c
pawn can still never be captured we
should be good to go here as white we're
going to continue with our plan
eventually capture the b-pawn and it'll
be good to go why is c3 drawing here
let's check it out black starts with
king to d5 and now after king g5 black
goes for this pawn break c5 but we
looked at this right we said this was
okay we'll just play b5 and now black
doesn't just wait idly they play c4
which looks like a terrible blunder
you're leaving this pawn undefended if
white ever gets opposition black's king
will be forced away from the defense and
black will be losing however black has a
very cute idea with this move king h6
king e6 king takes h7 it's very
important that you don't play king f7 as
black here you need to stay inside of
this box of this potential past b pawn
right if you play king f7 then a5 wins
for white however we don't want to play
king e7 either because this allows
opposition from white king g7 white gets
opposition so as black there's actually
only one drawing move here which is king
d7 distant opposition if you want to
learn more about distant opposition i've
made a video about it right there we'll
be seeing it a lot during this series so
even if you don't understand it right
now you will eventually begin to
understand it and see the importance of
it it's a very important and frequently
appearing concept in endgames which
black is using right now if king g6
black stays inside the box and maintains
opposition with king e6 but if you know
anything about opposition you know that
when you're looking for opposition you
have to ask yourselves two questions is
the opposition meaningful and can the
opposition be maintained and the answer
to both of those questions has to be yes
for the opposition to be worth it so it
may look like black is not actually
drawing this because this opposition
cannot be maintained black has to say
inside of this box so all white has to
do to gain opposition is come down to
the third rank they'll eventually gain
the opposition and be able to infiltrate
with something like this king g5 king e5
king g4 black can't step outside the box
so black ops to play king e6 diagonal
opposition but now we play king f3 king
d5 king f4 and black can no longer
maintain opposition we're inching our
way closer with white king e4 king c5
cannot be played otherwise the c pawn is
lost so black defends with king e5 but
white is still getting
opposition
with
stalemate
king
e5 and this was black's idea the whole
time it's a very cute and mind-blowing
resource i went very wild when i saw
this for the first time when i realized
that black had this stalemate defensive
resource there's no way for white to
break through in fact this was a draw
the whole time after white played the
mistake of c3 check so how do we prevent
black from using this stalemate resource
well we're still going to start with b4
king d4 but now as white we play king e6
now you can't bring this king too far
away as white because black is going to
play h5 to try to promote their own pawn
white must stay within this box here and
now only now after black has played h5
our king is guarding d5 only now do we
play c3 check the king is forced to c4
with the king on c4 black wife to spend
one extra move getting their king off of
c4 to get their pawn to c4 to set up the
stalemate and as white we use this to
our advantage king f5 king d5 king g5
now c5 whenever the c5 pawn break is
made we must play b5 as white black
continues setting up the stanway with c4
but now after king takes h5 it is white
who has distant opposition in the
previous variation it was black who had
distant opposition white had to come to
the third rank and infiltrate through
the e5 square however when white has
distant opposition white can infiltrate
black's position wherever they want for
example king e5 king g5 white will be
able to outflank black here in fact we
could even come up to the top of the
board if we want king e6 king g6 king e7
king g7 king e8 now we play king f6 king
d7 king f7 white will eventually inch
their way closer pick up the c pawn
promote one of their pawns and win the
game i hope you enjoyed those end game
studies and positions from devretsky's
endgame manual 5th edition you can buy
the book in the description below this
is not sponsored i just want to give
credit to where i got these positions so
if you enjoyed and want to see more cool
end game studies like this consider
picking up the book once again in the
description below thank you very much
for watching take care and i'll see you
next time